Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
here's a question about tipping at restaurants.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. I have been watching your
show for almost ten years. I turned 27 the other
day and I have been watching since I was 18. Wow.
I just wanted to ask you, what are your
thoughts on a tipping culture and if you
believe in tipping or if you think that
restaurants should pay living wage? Okay.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I am against tipping. I
don't want to I hate first of all, I hate
the ambiguity of how there are certain situations
where, of course, you know, you have to tip like
restaurants, but then there are others where it's
less clear and it creates bad situations, etc.. I
My preference would be a restaurant's list, prices
inclusive of the full salary of the people that
are working there. And you don't have to worry
about tipping. This is increasingly happening.
Lots of places in New York City are starting to do
that. The tipping culture is not only confusing to
people traveling between countries where the
policy or expectations are different, it's also
a way for restaurant owners to get out of actually
paying employees properly. I'm against tipping,
but I tip 20% for good service myself because I
know that it's not the fault of the restaurant
employees, that that's the system. But I would
like to get rid of it and have a system that is
much cleaner. Don't tip prices already account
for properly paying our staff. That's all you've
got to do. That would be my preference. We have
a great bonus show for you today. Sign up at join
Packman dot com to get instant access. We will see
you on the bonus show today or back on tomorrow.